this is this is the bismillah
alhamdulillah please be with you I'm
ready host you watching a Deen show and
have you ever cross came across an
individual individuals that you tried to
explain to him the purpose of life and
you get into all the fascinating things
that the verbatim Word of God talks
about and you try to just have them
reflect and think and the person steps
back says you know what I don't believe
in organized religion you know what
science dicks the way dictates the way
in my life it's all about science it's
all about this and they don't accept
what you're talking about because they
feel that you know what to be religious
you have to be illogical to be following
a way of life from the Creator it
doesn't make sense but Islam makes sense
of it all and we're going to be giving
you some more evidences and proofs to
help those sincere truth seekers
understand that the verbatim word of God
indeed is from the Creator that happens
in earth Islam is a system a way of life
that is from the creator of the heavens
and is based a lot of it is based on
scientific facts not fiction we're going
to be discussing those facts not fiction
here on the Deen show when we come back
this is the theme the Bijoux
this is the beach this is the days the
angel
this is the daisies betangel this is the
Salam alaikum wa allakum assalaam
Muhammad light or cutter who he's been
with you please Bo to president of the
IR EF you know Islamic research and
educational foundation Hyderabad India
and many consider you a scholar of
Christianity a student of Islam
Oh masha'Allah I feel very happy with
that you like that I love it
alright so let us get into this topic
we're going to be talking about you know
in today's world many people have
drifted away from from religion because
they feel that it conflicts with science
and many people they feel that to be
dwelling into religion is to just put
your brain on hold right it's just a
feeling you get it's you know opium but
when we as Muslims we say hold on no
it's not that because Islam was leading
the way in science Islam is based on
facts not Lullaby stories that you tell
your kids these are facts not fiction
some people have a hard time believing
it but they've tuned in today they're
like let me give these Muslims a shot
Muslims simply once who surrenders
submit to the one God it's the way of
life of Jesus Moses Muhammad and all the
message of the gap because the message
was one worship the crater not his
creation so how do you like to tackle
this topic it's very important like in
the Western world we find that specially
the Western community compared to many
other places in the world the Western
people especially the Europeans the
Americans they are more into the
progressive side of the world the
materialistic progress of the world
science and technology is speaking here
information is blasting everywhere today
so now please don't mistaken me with the
word blast and talking about the
information blast so information is
blasting everywhere now see with this
information coming the Christians of
Western countries who are reading the by
for a very long time they started
pondering now it's a good fine
they started pondering they started
finding what man what is this religion
the Bible is speaking so many things on
scientific when I read the book of
Genesis in Chapter number one verse
number one to verse number 30 you have
some scientific errors which says that
God created the world and the first day
passes the second day passes the third
day God creates the earth with the
vegetation and then on the fourth day
God creates the Sun what what are you
speaking man the first day is passing
the second day is passing the third day
is passing earth is created the
vegetation is growing and all this is
happening without the Sun without the
Sun there is the phenomena of the night
and the day so the Western scientists
the Western crystals are genius they are
pondering the book of Genesis chapter
number 1 verse number 1 to 30 you have
mistakes so they say no we don't believe
in this to be the Word of God then now
when you read without photosynthesis
process of photosynthesis without
sunlight there can't be photosynthesis
process this is the Bible you're talking
about
oh yeah the book of Genesis chapter
number one the very first book the
moment you open the Bible the Old
Testament the very first chapter of the
book of Genesis chapter number 1 verse
number 1 to verse number 13 on
scientific facts yeah so this is what
when the Christians were reading this
because in the Western world we had a
majority of the Christians living and
these people were getting educated they
were trying to learn the Word of God and
the modern scientific theories when they
were doing that what is this how can the
day first day second day third day
passed without the Sun there is no Sun
in the days are passing there is no Sun
and vegetation growing on the earth
unscientific then when you read the
first chapter again verse number 13 and
14 it says the Sun and the moon give
their own line they were shocked what
man
moon is a reflecting body it's not a
body giving its own light it is not a
star it's a satellite so these things
then when you read Genesis step number 1
verse number 29 and 30
it says everything on the earth is for
you to eat there are so many poisonous
things so these things and other
religions
when the worship making an idol of God
with one hand to hand for hand for legs
making an idol idol of a female God and
then showing a tongue coming out holding
the swords and all these things when
they see this they say is this the God
how can this be God we don't believe in
any God that is how it started and then
bad if you trace back the history the
Renaissance period the Industrial
Revolution period of the 19th century
you find there was a big tussle
happening between the churches and the
scientific community the church was very
strong there everything the people did
they would take a fatwa an opinion from
the church unless the opinion doesn't
come the King couldn't do anything the
heads of state couldn't do anything so
the scientists were getting so much
trouble from these religious places that
they thought one day let's tackle this
issue and Darwin came as a mercy for
those people at that time the scientists
when they saw Darwin is writing a book
origin of species with knack with the
means of natural selection published in
1859 where he only actually expressed
his personal views if you read that book
Darwin before propounding that book when
he went on HMS Beagle on a botanical
white he writes to his friend Thomas and
he says Thomas in a letter to Thomas he
says you see Thomas I don't have any
evidence with me to link my Curie's but
based on my own observations based on my
own observations I feel maybe evolution
took place he never claimed confessing
Lee confirmed Lee therefore you see we
still call it the theory of evolution
but at that time because there was a
tussle between the scientists and the
church the scientists together they gave
a big publicity to this theory in order
to put down the church and the religious
beliefs so as a whole if you observe an
atheist is trying to be a little
intelligent than many others who worship
other gods fake gods demigods or
associate false gods with the only to
god allah subhanaw taala so when he says
there is no God
Islamic Ali he has agreed to the initial
part of the Islamic Creed which is la
ilaha there is no God what he needs to
understand is there is no God of the
gods you are seeing in the world but
there is a God who is the god and that
is Allah subhana Allah that we need to
educate this atheist
these people are generally referred as
80s meaning they do not believe in God
and it is very difficult believe me it's
very difficult to talk to these atheists
the reason you want to speak to the
Christian you hold the Bible you say
your Bible says this your Bible says
that a Christian wants to talk to the
Muslim he holds the Quran we want to
talk to the Jew
we hold the Tanakh the Torah the Navy
and the K to him which they refer a
Jewish scripture we say this is what is
in the tunnel in the Talmud or the
Mishnah or the Mishnah this is what we
talk to them but speaking to an atheist
he has no platform so individually you
have to deal with them but still there
are some general ways where you can deal
with an atheist one thing the atheist
actually tries to be is tries to prove
himself
smarter than the people following the
religion is he tries to say as you said
rightly in the initiating this show you
said he tries to prove that he is very
scientific
so if he is talking about science he
needs to understand that the greatest of
the scientists iced Edison copper
nickels and their likes they all
believed in religion and the God known a
you named Einstein who was so a name so
many scientists these were prominent
scientists believed and they believed in
religion and God and Einstein even has a
popular statement to give he says
science without a religion is lame and a
religion without science is blind so
what we Muslims are saying is if you say
Bible is unscientific I stand by I agree
Bible is unscientific you bring any
other scripture every little scripture
yes there are many things
unscientific but Subhan Allah Allah my
god I swear the Quran has so many things
which are scientific spoken at a time
when there was no way of speaking those
subjects no chance of a human being
talking about those things with you and
me as human population of the modern
world just discovered a few years back
we're gonna have to take a break and I'm
gonna have you go into these when we
come back show inshallah God willing
we'll be right back fish are here on the
Dean shop exactly whatever Allah
commands even you need to move this land
has tolerance and mercy and compassion
to know that Allah you know will forgive
you as long as you do what you need to
do as long as you turn back to him Islam
is a system of mercy and compassion and
it is for the best benefit of all of the
people that surround it Muslim and
non-muslim
motion
back here in a Dean show with the
president of the IR EF Bible scholar he
considers himself just a student of the
Koran which you have a lot of knowledge
of the crown also little uh prefer not
to be called shake move Dean mallanna
yeah let me just call you brother Imran
yeah may God Almighty Allah the Creator
has an item the same God Jesus worship
that's the God Muhammad called us to
worship because he was the last and
final messenger and that's what we're
doing we're continuing the legacy of
only way shipping God and not his
creatures true so we discussed the
inaccuracies unscientific things that
are mentioned in the Bible that later
started a conflict with people of reason
of people of science of intellect
they're like holy this can't be from God
this can't be right because it's
contrary to human intellect and science
so there was a clash right civilization
true but you're saying that the Quran is
unlike any of these books because it's
not man-made
it's from the Creator from the create
and it has scientific facts hundred that
are verifiable verifiable come on give
it give it Allah what are you holding
back a lot a lot you give up yeah cool
ok let's have is easy for waiting you
see time is money brother yeah my child
on my chili it's more precious
underlined
they're waiting now hostage Allah if you
observe one thing before I go in deep
about the Quran let me first introduce
very briefly what the Quran is the Quran
is unlike any other religious scripture
on the face of the earth this Quran is
the only religious Scripture on the face
of the earth existing today since the
time it was first revealed to prophet
Moses on in its original form no other
scripture except the Quran is in its
original form from the time of mama so
somewhat has been written what was
preserved by his companions even today
those copies are preserved in British
India Museum in Istanbul all these
places you will find them preserved take
those copies telle them with any copy of
the Quran anywhere in the world
you will not find an iota of a
difference not a full stops difference
not a commas difference so this is one
of the miracle of the Quran de other
miracle of the Quran is all languages in
the world tend to change in their
vocabulary within a century but Quran
since
14:30 years after its revelation still
has made arabic remain the same language
quran has saved arabic language
mashallah what was revealed fourteen
thirty years back and Arabs speaking
today reading the Quran he understands
it exactly and this never happens with
any other language of the world you just
check English died down
outdated words now no common person can
understand it but the Quran is
understood this is a miracle of the
Quran now the question is if the non
Muslim brothers and sisters the atheists
especially they have never read this
Quran properly they never read it if
they would have read the Quran and
pondered a little bit they would have
been observed and pondered to themselves
bringing it to their mind how man how
can this be possible
fourteen thirty years back the Quran is
revealed to some person by the name
Muhammad Encyclopedia Brittanica records
from the life of Muhammad sallallahu
sallam Prophet Muhammad he was born in
570 Christian era 570 years after Jesus
Christ may peace be upon him he is born
in the desert of Arabia in Makkah in the
city of Makkah and then this person he
grows up forty years he is in the midst
of all his people all his people are
watching him grow for forty years and
they know him as an amine if you read
surah jumma surah number 62 I have
number five so they are off so number
seven as number 157 Allah says my
messenger is an o me who me is an Arabic
word which means who does not know how
to read and write if you read surah and
kabul surah number twenty nine Allah
subhana Allah says in surah and Kabuto
surah number 29 that vomit koonta mint
that lumen kitab in o prophet you are
not the one to recite any book before
this nor could you write it with your
right hand had you been able to read and
write the talkers of vanities would have
doubted that you produce the Quran so he
didn't have a PhD at that time oh not a
peon no forget PhD he could not write
his own name he didn't know how to read
and write so if the atheist has this
background about the Quran then he
starts reading he will be like
oh man what is this this person he
didn't know how to read and write he is
living in the deserts of Arabia and the
Arabian people are uncivilized
historians have documented Oh to ask
Airlines Thomas Carlyle in his book
heroes and heels you know worship he
talks so much about the Arabs the Arabs
of the time before grow up with Moses
l'm brought the quran to them from Allah
subhana Allah they were considered the
human garbage on earth
Alexander passes by them Julius Caesar
passes by them but does not consider
worth ruling over there because it's a
desert land
nothing worth to take out they didn't
know that patrol existed there they
didn't know at the time had they known
it like today there would have been so
many fights in the deserts of Arabia
back at that time like we find it today
for the petrol but they didn't had at
that time because they didn't know this
is so the desert they pass by it so now
they coming up and they pass all this up
and this is divinely being set up
finally being set up so now the atheists
like ok I get it this guy he problem
Hamid peace be upon him last - final
messenger they look at his history and
they see that look he didn't know how to
read or write he wasn't a PhD even if he
even if he was he still can produce this
book by the way correct absolutely but
he was it was it so now it talks about
the human development of the embryo it
talks about talks about so many times in
the talk about these things so please
to begin with just imagine the Big Bang
Theory Big Bang Theory because this is
what atheist they'll rest oh yes look
look Big Bang Big Bang Theory it's a Big
Bang what's the Big Bang Theory so they
say in 1970s in the early 1970s this was
propounded what is the Big Bang Theory
so they say the entire universe was in
the form of a nebula and there was a big
bang and with that Big Bang the Sun got
produced the stars got created
everything in the heavens and earth in
the universe got created with this Big
Bang can you imagine
Prophet Muhammad on the authority of
Allah speaks about the Big Bang fourteen
hundred and thirty years back which
human beings discovered hardly in 1970s
and fourteen thirty years back six
hundred and
10% error the Koran started to be
revealed to Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu
salam continued to be revealed for 33
years from 610 for 23 years from 610 to
633 the quran was revealed to prophet
moses are you saying the Big Bang is
mentioned in surah MBI surah number 21
at number 30 Allah says o Allah we are
Allah's Enoch afar 1 s-samawati will
earth do not the disbelievers in Islam
do not the non-muslims look at the
creation of the heavens and the earth
--kavitha returned they were joined
together as one unit of creation for
Fatah Kannamma and we closed them
ascender and the Arabic word cannot
eruption fluttershy in Arabic it means
two separate bodies joined so closely
that when you look at them they appear
just one can you imagine how pinpoint
the Big Bang Theory is mentioned then we
were taught in our schools what is the
basic unit of life the answer comes
water life is made from water and then
we were taught cytoplasm is the basic
unit of life it contains 80% of water
and 20% of plasma the size advanced
nineteen hundred and fifty dr. Watson he
discovers the miracle item the miracle
item i tem the miracle item of our time
the DNA he discovered 1950 dr. Watson
discovers then we say DNA is the basic
unit of life for every living thing now
in late 1990s the medical scientists
they try to find out fine man DNA is the
basic unit of life fine but how does the
DNA itself survive so they came to the
conclusion in 1990s that the DNA for its
own survival it consumes the hydrogen
ions from the water water molecule h2o
meaning DNA is the basic unit of life
for everything and the basic unit of
life for everything consumes the water
molecule for its own survival and the
Quran in surah MBI surah number 21 ID
number 33 0 it says the last portion of
the Big Bang Theory ayah that I just
recited the last push
Allah says Allah me mama e Kalasha in
high of allah me known we made life from
the water still will you not believe and
imagine can you imagine this part Quran
is revealed to Prophet Muhammad in
desert where for a drop of water Prophet
Muhammad and his companions would travel
miles to collect a drop of water and
Quran is saying we created life from the
water and Prophet Muhammad and his
companion C Samina Wattana rasoolallah
we heard what you said this is from
Allah we obeyed this is from Allah
that's our Iman mashallah
who can speak this fourteen thirty years
back is the question we're gonna take a
break and we'll be right back with more
and to wrap it up here in the Deen show
is the Medina
he's did you say that you're not believe
in Jesus you have stepped outside of his
name you can not be a Muslim is
attending our faith to believe in and
love Jesus Christ by these the why is it
then when it comes to one of the most
important decisions in life and
literally abuse ourselves it's not that
the main thing we're looking for is to
see what type of money he has so that he
can treat my daughter like a princess
it's not about back here in the D show
and we're talking to the world we're
talking to the atheist the person who is
trying to use his logic he said there's
no God out there we agree except the one
true guy he just got to come a little
step further he don't want to worship a
monkey or a man or a woman he's like
this but you know what even an atheist
ends up worshiping something of the
creation he ends up doing that because
when you go away from worshiping the
crater you end up wishing bring yourself
maybe your desires right or maybe that
money that woman material things right
good luck bad luck all these other
things so you are making a god out there
if you're not worshiping the one god but
we're giving facts nonfiction about the
scientific facts that you can ponder
over and we gave a few that you will
come to conclude that there's no way
that this man was getting this
information but from the creator of the
heavens in ur so go on the embryo the
embryo key film or talk about this is
ofcourse young McKay says they can go
check themselves of course first we
talked about the universe yeah basic
unit of life Keith Moore he is the Dean
embryology of the Toronto Medical
University in Canada the descriptions of
the human embryo and the Quran cannot be
based on scientific knowledge in the
seventh century man yeah the main man
the main person there of embryology he
wrote a book the human development and
this book is referred as the syllabus
book for the medical students in several
universities of the world here are two
volumes he was about to write the third
volume when some Muslim students of
Saudi Arabia they went to dr. kit Mon
they say dr. kit mode this is a
translation of the Quran we want you to
check surah number 96 surah Alaka ayat
number 2 1st 2nd 3rd 4th and 5th I add
these feiiow of surah al-ahqaf surah
number 96 for the first revelation to
mohammad sallallahu Solem they said
please check it dr. kid more and tell us
what do you say about this because Allah
says kala kalah in Sangamon allah we
created the mankind from allah so please
tell us about the alaq
so dr. Keith Moore said give me some
time for research he made the research
he came in the 8th medical conference
held in Saudi Arabia Riyadh
international medical conference the
video is there of this statement of
Keith Moore
it was invited day and when he came
there they asked him dr. Kittner have
you found out so dr. Kidman said he as I
found out they are the what did you find
he said to my surprise I took an Arabic
to English lexicon I opened it I checked
the meaning of the word ha ha it had
three meanings something appearing like
a leech or a blood clot something that
thinks to something and something that
sucks and to mine shocking surprise this
embryo at this state particular it has
all the three perfect meanings
applicable to it they said how so you
said when you look at that embryo at
that particular stage if you read the
third volume of the human development
the diagrams are given there if you look
at the diagram of the human embryo in
the mother's womb it appears to be like
a leech or a blood clot then this is the
first time when the human embryo stings
itself is it attaches itself to the
uterine wall of the mother and it sucks
its food from they you
all of the mother from it is a uterine
pipe that the blood flows to the breast
to produce the milk so it sucks its food
he says all the three meanings were
perfect so what do you say now so he
said I have no doubt to accept that this
Quran is not a human production book it
is impossible for any human being to
know about it if you reach for a
mu'minin' surah number 23 at number 12
13 and 14 all the stages of the human
baby till the baby grows out of the
mother's womb from the time the sperm
falls in the mother's womb is given
there on all this dr. Keith Moore says
third volume I completed by studying
accept the Quran there is no other book
on earth that can give the best stages
about the human embryo
how can Prophet Mohammed 14 30 years
back give them when possible journalists
as always the media person they played
again again as they always do against
Islam they go to get more and they say
you say that kid more maybe Prophet
Muhammad was an illiterate person he
must have cut open the boom of a
pregnant woman he must have seen it and
written down in the Quran so his idea
you are right but partially so this
Ellen said is that true he said yes but
partially because after doing grad after
hiding in the Quran Prophet Muhammad hid
the microscope in the desert land they
laughed they said of the kid for what
happened to you
there was no microscope at the time of
Prophet Muhammad SAW Salaam so he says
the laugh is back at you because why
because man it cannot be seen with a
normal microscope that is the condition
of the embryo where you need a powerful
microscope to see then how can Prophet
Mohammed see only with the naked eye -
right
this is from truly the all-mighty God
dr. Taylor Seth is the same another
medical scientist from Thai University
of Bangkok he was made a research and he
came in a medical conference an
international medical conference he was
so joyous he said I have come with a new
research when you receive a burn it is
not the nervous system responsibility to
give you the feeling the sensation of
the pain there are sensory cells beneath
your skin they give you the pain so the
Muslim doctor was there he said dr.
Taylor thought the same we know it from
the Quran fourteen thirty years back he
said what impossible
please take the Koran check surah nisa
surah number 4 at number 56 and when
made a study came back the 8th medical
conference when he was asked what do you
say now he said I have nothing to say
about the Quran except that I declare in
front of everybody
la ilaha illallah muhammad rasoolullah
there is no other God besides Allah
Muhammad is the Messenger of Allah
what was the aisle and law says in surah
an-nisa surah number 4 at number 56
whoever disbelieves in islam the
disbelievers because they did not
believe in the truth of Allah and Islam
the disbelievers will be punished in the
Hellfire and when their skills get
roasted we shall give them new skills
upon new skills so that they keep
feeling the pain the sensation of the
burning of the Hellfire how can this be
produced in the Quran 14:30 is bad Quran
talks about the fingerprint fingerprint
is different when did we know 1790 Sir
Francis Gray said that but we knew about
it only in 1790 the Quran speaks about
it in surah Keawe surah number 75 ad
number 1 2 3 we know about so many
things today the Quran speaks much
earlier about it so an atheist should
actually ponder on all this dr. Morris
book hail offense surgeon who wrote a
book Allah Bible at la Quranic law
science he said the Bible the Quran and
the science and in that book he came out
with several scientific errors in the
Bible and he became a Muslim he was a
French surgeon and he we come to know
today that this Quran that we read has
about 1000 ayat 1000 I oughta generally
miss translated in English as vs. 1000
ayat that deal purely with medical
science meaning about one sixth of the
Quran deals with medical science of
those 1000 ayat about 750 to 780 ayah
had been agreed upon by the science
today that were in the Quran since
fourteen thirty years the size recently
came to know yes they are true about the
remaining 250 to 220 iaat the science is
still backward it does not have the
means to measure the IR it can either
say they are right nor wrong the Quran
is more at one when the science
and we Muslims for us Quran is the scale
to judge the science we don't take size
as the scale to judge the Quran that is
how we need to promote to the atheist
about all this amazing may we're out of
time we're out of time one important
fact just a miracle of the Quran the
verbatim Word of God is amazing if you
come at it with a sincere open mind
humble heart the guidance is there but
you got to want it and the facts not
fiction are there but you got to want it
and we've given just a taste so people
can ponder over but there's so much more
we get to talked about this expounding
on it for hours tell us also just before
we leave you mentioned something about
the miracle or just the Prophet his the
last final message or problem hama peace
be upon him who came with the same
message of Jesus Noah Abraham Moses to
worship the One God do good deeds and
warn people about the the wonderful
wards of paradise accountability on the
day of judgment and the Hellfire you
talked about for following your desires
and turning away from the signs of God
it's a sign of God if you watching now
here you got to reflect and really think
because these facts are amazing you
mentioned just the prophets life how its
and how a person can go back and go into
it in detail how it's been miraculously
preserved how he did that how he did
this expound on this for a second a
normal person would go crazy if
traveling away to see this is one thing
the prophets of Allah Islam I always see
I always feel the Prophet as a person
was itself a great miracle of allah
subhanaw taala
the person Prophet Muhammad Prophet
Muhammad is a miracle of Allah
subhanAllah himself the reason for that
you see perfect moments awesome in the
Quran in surah as absolute number 33
eizember 21 Allah says laka the kana
lakum fee Rasul Allah he was rotten
husana the best example for the mankind
is in Muhammad's Allah Allah's Salam for
all mankind for the Muslims and the
non-muslims too
he is the best example can you imagine
he has nothing as privacy no privacy no
privacy for him because the reason when
Allah said he is the example he walks
outside the house and he has all the
companions microscopy microscopically
watching him how does he said
how does his mind how does he relax how
does he shift his hey how does he turn
around how does he look at others how
does he look when he becomes angry how
does he move his eyes then how does he
weigh the sleeper how does he wear his
clothes how does it talk to others what
are the statements he gives everything
there is somebody noting down getting
somebody noting down the whole day
everyone is watching him just watching
him it's a hobby comes from another
place to Madinah it was summer in medina
the Prophet rule or Islam was sitting he
had the buttons on the top of his shirt
two of them unlocked they were not put
on this hobby sees him returns back he
kept the buttons always like that for
his old shirt when the people ask what's
this he said I saw my prophet that way
so that shows how microscopically they
were trying to observe everything salah
prophet muhammed sallalahu salaam when
he is outside everyone is watching him
not just the Muslim Sahaba then
non-muslim people the non-muslims the
pagans of Makkah they are watching him
that is believers in Islam they are
watching the reason this person is
talking something but is it practicing
that or is it not practicing that
everyone is watching him and now imagine
the situation amazingamazing
he is a little relaxed enters the house
the moment he puts his foot in the house
his wives are observing him
how is our husband sitting because he is
not just our husband is the Rasul of
Allah
how does he sit in the house how does he
lie on the bed
how does he ask us to serve Him how does
he behave with us he is so happy with us
he is so good to us so kind to us so
humble to us we are so enjoying with him
he educates us he takes care of the
homely affairs what kind of a person is
this and now when he is lies down on the
bed to sleep he is in the sleep and
still he is being watched
how does he sleep when you see when he
is sleeping
how does he look imagine man he would
commit suicide if somebody keeps
watching us this way and after so many
is watching him it's not cameras
technologically the camera can go wrong
human eyes are constantly watching him
and unanimously all the eyes that
watched him had no other option but to
accept his Amin and asada the most
trustworthy to give what Allah gave to
him and the most truthful of all as far
as his characters were concerned the
non-muslims also agreed that he was the
best of all amazing to me we got a girl
we got a cut-out I've enjoyed talking to
you and I'm sure everybody out there is
enjoying the show people can look you up
at the IR EF research and educational
foundation has about India they can go
to the youtube guide I M R am Imran , I
re f in capital and they've got the
YouTube videos on it inshallah very soon
our video our website is under
renovation and that would come soon ir e
f wo rld i re a world dot o-r-g that is
a website somebody wants to make a call
to India our number is plus nine one
four zero six six seven seven four four
one one it is an easy number double nine
one double zero nine one four zero
double six double seven double four
double one does number anybody can call
back in India except on Friday Fridays
we are closed by God Almighty the
creator black allah khair islamic thank
you well lagos and peace be with you and
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Dean show deaf is a
reality can approach every time so the
matter is serious we really really gotta
ponder what's the purpose of life and
Islam gives you all the facts not
fiction on what you need to be doing in
this life so you could be successful in
this life and the next day a judgment
accountability you're going to be either
rewarded or you're going to be
punishment punished you're either going
to be earning the reward of Jenna
paradise or you're going to have a place
in the Hellfire it's a fact and it's not
fiction and that is what the show is all
about to help you reflect about the
purpose of life and help you develop a
better understanding on why you've been
created and where you're going when you
die and what you need to be doing of
good in this life so you can be
successful and have
peace in this life and in the next we'll
see you next time continue to tune in
also get a free verbatim word of god the
quran called the number 1 800 662 islam
or go ahead and ask any of those
questions that are lingering in the back
of your mind
so again you can have a better
understanding we'll see you next time
peace be unto you